it was a unanimous decision five
Constitutional Court judges nullified
Mays presidential election result saying
Peter Metallica did not win a second
term fresh elections have to be held
within 150 days opposition leaders who
were caught welcomed the ruling judgment
justice has prevailed and thou shalt
make further comments after reading the
final judgement thank you
we came to suggest this week just got it
celebrations erupted in opposition
strongholds judges said there were too
many inconsistencies in Mays election
some people may have voted more than
once there was barrett stuffing and
using in 2017 king a supreme court and
now that country's presidential election
because of your regularities malawi is
not the second sub-saharan country to
have a presidential vote overturned by
any other party the future possibly to
simply do certain things underhand and
it was in france is the point that you
need to go back and invest into
electoral system should we continue on
the first-past-the-post for we should
now start looking at 50-plus run or any
other system that we would be eventually
secured or assure of a free and fair
election for months they've been
demonstrations in several parts of the
country over mazes peters election some
of those have been violent
Metallica's ruling DPP party can appeal
the constitutional ruling at the supreme
court no one from the party was willing
to go on camera after Monday's
constitutional court ruling the country
is tense earlier on Monday the streets
of the capital a long way or eerily
quiet many people chose to stay at home
not sure what's going to happen next
how a rerun of elections is handled
could improve or deepen Malawi's
political and economic crisis her
Matassa al-jazeera Lilongwe